So what's the difference between formal and informal writing styles?
Well,...
I tend to be complex and thorough.
I'm simple and more conversational.
I take on more serious topics in a very direct way.
Well, I use a larger range of emotions and show more personality.
Wait, I can see how this is going to end.
Let's explain this one at a time.
Formal writing, you're first.
Step up to the microphone.
Thank you.
Like I said before I'm complex and thorough.
I use longer sentences...
...and each of my main points are introduced, elaborated on, and concluded.
My articles use full words, not contractions or abbreviations.
My writing is objective.
I state the main points confidently and offer a full support of arguments.
I am not a personal writing style.
So, there are very few emotions included.
Thank you for your time.